[Music]
welcome everybody to low on Prime daily
I'm Jesse Weber the man accused of
brutally stabbing four college students
to death inside of an Idaho home will
have to stay behind bars that decision
came down Thursday during a short status
hearing Brian coburger appeared in court
alongside his public defender he
acknowledged that he understands the
charges that are against him and waved
his right to a speedy trial this case
involves investigations from multiple
jurisdictions and the attorneys will
need some time to gather up everything
coburger a 28 year old working toward a
PhD in criminology at Washington State
University is accused of killing Ethan
Chapin Zana kernodle Kaylee Gonzalez and
Madison Logan at the nearby University
of Idaho the students were murdered on
November 13th but police didn't release
information about a suspect until about
six weeks later and during that time
Brian coburger and his father made a
cross-country road trip back to his
parents home in Pennsylvania that is
where coburger was officially arrested
and brought back to Idaho to face murder
charges a probable cause affidavit
connects co-burger to the crime using
DNA cell phone data and more during
Thursday's hearing the judge said a
preliminary hearing date of June 26 and
said there will be quote no bail at this
point in time long crime hosted a q a
after the hearing where veteran FBI
agent Bobby Chacon answered a question
about circumstantial evidence
with circumstantial evidence it's the
accumulation right it's the totality of
it it's not the one particular piece I
see people picking apart little pieces
but but prefer a jury and during a long
trial it's the totality of that
circumstantial evidence that's billed
it's an accumulation thing it builds and
builds and builds to the point where
juror reaches that point Beyond any
reasonable doubt because of the amount
of it it's not necessarily the quality
or the the the the the attackability of
any particular piece of evidence but
it's the accumulation of that in that
circumstantial evidence that then gives
rise to that Beyond Reasonable Doubt
standard
time to bring in my co-host and public
defender Brian buckmeyer Brian good to
see you this was quick hearing we know
that preliminary hearing this summer
that's going to be the one that
everybody's going to watch what can you
tell us about it yeah Jesse preliminary
hearings are something that the defense
can request or waive here the defense
has chosen to have one so if all stays
the same till late June we'll likely see
that what looks like a mini trial
preliminary hearings are where a
Magistrate Judge determines if there is
probable cause to believe that a felony
occurred and that it was the defendant
who committed it I usually tell my
clients it's asking if it's more likely
than not that this person did it if the
judge agrees case goes to district court
for arraignments and the case continues
if not the case can be dismissed or
charges amended but we may not see the
hearing because the defense can ask to
exclude the public if they can prove the
public hearing would deny coburger a
fair trial and there are no reasonable
alternatives to keeping the public out
June 26 is a long ways away with the
defense wave coburger's right to a
speedy trial so the case isn't going
anywhere anytime soon this gives the
defense the time to do their own and
investigation collect evidence they've
demanded from the prosecution and try to
convince the judge there's no probable
cause in the preliminary hearing okay
let me bring in now Terry Austin or
other co-host and former trial attorney
Brian outlined the whole criminal
process including the purpose of the
preliminary hearing but do you think the
prosecution is going to have enough
evidence at that hearing to actually
move the case forward I do I think like
Brian said both the defense and the
prosecution will be gathering additional
evidence they have till June 26th it's
probably going to be four or five days
but right now the prosecution I think
has enough evidence remember they have
that DNA on the knife sheath they have
the fact that he was in the area and
they got that from the cell phone tower
and you know they also have a
description from DM the witness the
other one of the other surviving victims
in this issue in this you know whole
case but I do think that the prosecution
is going to get additional information
remember they have searched the parents
home they've searched his home they've
searched the car they could find DNA
from one of the victims or they could
find other information that will make
the case even stronger so it's good to
give them the additional time yeah and
look you know who knows if anybody has
anything about Brian coburger saying
anything as well that might come out as
well so this is a case constantly motion
and we're going to cover it here on Long
crime daily